[Music]
ha no you took just lovers and her
friends this is guns in here welcome to
the 27th episode of dirty chest trick in
this episode I am going to show you one
of the most amazing and wonderful trick
against specific line of the patter of
offense
now the patter of or the Russian defense
arises after the Mordor efore ePHI
Knight to f3 Knight to f6 the main line
continued with the Moon Knight captures
ePHI d6 Knight to f3 and now black
regain his pawn with the move Knight
captures evil in the 21st episode of
dirty chess freak I have covered the
move Queen to e2 which leads to the last
girl attack so if you haven't watched
that video I strongly insist you to
watch it as I have covered some cool
tricks including a queen trap line now
the main move in this position is d4 but
personally I don't like that move the
simple reason is it allowed black to
play the move defy and liberate his
position so that's why at this position
I'm going to recommend a very tricky
move c4 as you can see the simple idea
of c4 is to prevent the immediate move
defy and liberate the dark square Bishop
the mainline continue with the move
Bishop to d7 where now I should continue
with the moon d4 and as I have
highlighted over here black has two good
choices amongst them castle on the
kingside is one of the most popular
choice by the black but just for the
brief note if you oppor and played the
Moon Knight to c6 then you can directly
transpose into the male line why are the
more order Bishop to d3 defy castle on
the
side and now the moon night to be for
kindly look into the theory section for
more detailing about this line but we
are going to concentrate on the main
line which is the castle on the Kings
side and after that why should continue
with the move Bishop to d3 now as I have
highlighted over here black has three
different choices amongst them Knight to
g5 is the most strongest reply and that
is the move which I am going to
concentrate on the rest of the video
however I have covered other lines in
the PGN which is available in the
description which will give you a very
good idea how you should proceed if you
open and place that move just to give
you a glimpse of it if you open and
place the move fi then the problem is
white can play the mood de fire in the
later middle game and then plunk a piece
on the e6 which is always giving white a
good advantage the problem with the move
Knight to f6 is after the move Knight to
c3 not only white obtained a very good
center but white two bishops are looking
very aggressively on black King side and
the most important factor is if you
compare this dark square Bishop black
Bishop on e7 is completely blocked up so
considering all this factor at this
point Knight to g5 is one of the best
choice for the black blacks idea is to
exchange as many air species and slowly
improve his position pay attention over
here that black has a threat of Bishop
to g4 so that's why as per the online
database many provide players has
exchanged this night where I personally
found that resulting position is very
boring in the May 2016
super grandmaster nippon-ichi reached
this position against a 2600 rated
player and he comes with this great
novelty Knight to c3 which sets up a
very
vicious freak at first sight it looks
like white has made a big mistake
because now black can play the move
Bishop to g4 not only pressurizing the
f3 square but getting a wonderful
position well yes it's true except one
thing that black has strayed away fallen
into the white tricky cam the trick
start with the move Bishop captures g5
so we are destroying the one attacker
kindly note black responses force black
cannot play Bishop captures f3 the
simple reason is after Queen captures f3
and Bishop captures G Phi white can take
this b7 pawn and remain a solid pawn of
for the rest of the game in case if you
are afraid of this rook check then let
me remind you that it's nothing because
white can block this chat with the night
and now black doesn't have time to play
a fire because his own rook Hanks so
black has to continue with the move
Knight to d7 afterwards white can simply
castle on the Kings side and remain a
solid pawn up so considering that
variation Bishop to g4 is force at this
position and still let's look like not
only black has obtained a bishop pair
but that f3 Knight is badly pin and on
top of everything White has this deadly
rook check so the big question arises
how white get a winning edge from this
position before I move on I like you to
pause this video and find out if you are
a white in this position how you will
proceed okay I hope you find this
wonderful blow boom well personally when
I gone through this game I didn't find
that move the first important point to
note over here is if the King to h8 then
after Bishop to e4 White is a clear pawn
up so that's why black has to accept
this
and after that can you see whites next
amazing reply I hope you did and indeed
find this ingenious move h4 guara
freaking move okay before we start
looking at various options for the black
you should always note that rook to e8
is not a thread because I can always
play the MU King to f1 and the thread
remained as it is in the game of Nippon
mushy his friend is 600 plus rated
opponent continue with the move Bishop
to d2 and give up the bishop we're wide
obtain a clear point advantage and I
have included that game in the PG n
which will give you a very good idea how
what should proceed well he is a
material up
in this position black has various
choice and I have highlighted them by
the arrows so let's look at each bite on
the first more I want to consider is
Bishop captures f3 which is not a good
move the simple reason is after H
captures g5
white deliver the discover check and
after King to g8 and Queen captures f3
not only white regain his material but
at this point white is a clear pawn up
now just to illustrate how dangerous
this position is for the black I like to
show you one of my game where my 2,000
rated opponent continued with the move
Queen captures g5 I respond with the
move rook to h5 and now he give me this
check which is I consider as a mistake
because not only white can comfortably
put his King on
d2 where he's quite safe but now that
other rope joining into the party my
opponent continued with the move Knight
to c6 attacking d4 but first he has to
deal with the maid threat and I'm afraid
the game is already gone
he tried fi but after Queen to defy he
simply resigned because what is going to
checkmate black in the two steps
the second move I want to consider is
Bishop captures h4 next idea is if you
capture with the roof then he can
sacrifice this queen and get a very good
position well of course we should avoid
it and play accurate move Queen to d3
checker after King to g8 and rook
captures h5 not only white attacking
that Bishop but there is a checkmate
threat on at seven there's only one way
to stop both the thing that is fi and
with this move black has again created a
thread so white has to pay attention and
play the move rook - H - and now the
open edge file avenues a pretty
devastating for the black camp for
example a one online game continue with
the move rook to e8 check King to d2
this is a base location for the King
where he is quite safe and allowed the
doubling of the rook black continue with
the move Knight to c6 and I think white
has played the best move in this
position that is Knight to d5
black desperately looking for the
counter play continue with the move
Bishop captures and after pawn captures
he delivered this check but then white
continue with the MU King to c3 and now
white has some good threats which black
defended with the move rook a to c8 but
the move which was on the card for a
while
rook a to H fun and I think black is
already busted it was a blitz game where
black position fallen apart very quickly
he continued with the move Knight to e7
but then comes Knight captures rook
captures and this rook check proves very
deadly as it never the piece and in fact
the game
last but not least what happens if you
open place Bishop to at 6:00 we're here
the wide response is very obvious why
has to deliver this night jack
and if the King moves then but can
simply NAB the bishop if Bishop captures
g5 then again the simplest is ed g5
which gives a Discoverer check to the
king and white regain his peace so the
most critical line in this variation is
what happens if you open and take this
night with the Queen well here white
response is force white has to accept
this Queen trade that is ed G Phi Bishop
captures Queen and now rook captures
given okay white is temporarily a piece
down but this Bishop is not going
anywhere
and I like to show you some of the
sample games at this point which will
give you a very good idea how easily
white gate of been engage the first moon
looks very obvious rook to e8 check
White has to play King to d2 and now
there are two Knight moves we need to
consider if you operon plays Knight to
d7 then the simplest is you take this
Bishop and after pawn takes not only
blacks fall structures are completely
shattered on the King side but as I have
highlighted by the arrows white has a
simple but very effective plan it can
exploit this weaknesses more critical is
Knight to c6 which attacks the d4 pawn
but here white has a strong deploy
Knight to d5 so white has some more
potent threat so black has to defend
this with the move rook a to see it and
now my following game against a 2100
rated give you a very good idea how Y
should proceed from here onwards here I
continue with the MU capturing the
bishop kindly note black cannot touch
this pawn because Knight to f6 will nab
in exchange so my opponent continue with
the Moon Knight captures d4 I played
pawn cactus g7 discover
back to the king my opponent capture
this pawn and now I attack his Knight
with the move edge for this position is
more poisonous than you think
for example in the game my opponent
played Knight to f5 hitting my rook but
then comes rook check King to her fate
and now rook to h1 amazingly from
nowhere White has created deadly mating
net after a long caught my opponent come
up with the Moo abscess
I'm afraid doesn't solve the problem
before I move on I like you to pause
this video and find out a forcing
sequence which checkmate the black King
did you find it
let's see the first move is rook check
King to f7 ah now again rook check King
to f8 and now the star move Knight to f6
which create two threats and black
cannot defend both of them well I hope
you enjoy and long this wonderful trick
against the Petrov defense remember that
once the black has played Bishop to g4
then he's in a mood of giving you the
full point thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment on my video and I'll meet you in
my next episode very soon bye and take
care
discover attack to the king and after
any Knight moves which blocks the
diagonal let's say Knight D to e Phi
then we have this night jack which again
trapped the baby which at first sight
looks very threatening because it's
attacking to sports but as happens in
the most of the scenario that takes
favours the brave and here
Black has this amazing saving resource